hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today a video called
sorry to bother you explained in seven
minutes oh boy
this is from the channel let me explain
you see at our patreon we do weekly Q&A
z' TV show reaction watch lungs and john
does music video coverage that I
occasionally am in with him as well and
one of our top of work tears whatever
video you requested must definitely do
put up on the youtubes even means it
might possibly get blocked will try and
today comes from our good friend Jay
how's it going Jay a little backstory on
this video not this specific one but our
journey to watching this video I saw
sorry to bother you many months ago it's
a very strange movie and John hadn't
seen it and I told Jay that I'm going to
tell John to watch this movie and then
after he watches it we can cover this
video because I don't want to ruin for
him as I feel like John would probably
really like this movie such a strange
and weird movie that I'd rather just
John watch it first and then we could
watch this and John did watch quite
enjoyed quite enjoyed and all the great
Golden Globe nominations yeah anyway
let's check it out I could use a
refresher hope they explained some stuff
a little cuz I remember after it was
done watching it I had to go online to
be like so what was like oh what a cool
explanation boots Riley then I just kind
of left my mind is that very literal I
could go for it again to see what's up I
because I want to talk about a movie I
want to talk about a movie
obviously I also started meeting with my
rating because you know I want you guys
to experience the movies for yourself I
give you my rating you can go check them
out if you like and then we get
interesting with you where I break it
down this is one way you don't want to
get it spoiled especially with that
dirty because well I know that some of
you are gonna go in yeah maybe not gonna
buy with that ending some of you guys
will love it it's one of those movies
where because of where you fall there's
a lot to break down oh yeah here's what
I get out of it
let me explain so if you don't know
boots Riley Mansa gee he's making music
in several projects for years he
actually wrote this movie back in 2012
when we were all supposed to hire
something but it said he came out with
an album that had the same title as the
movie so it's kind of like a soundtrack
that came out years before the film was
even released he then made it into a
book and now we got the movie which is
one of my favorites of the year now one
of the biggest reasons why I like it is
because it's indirectly yet directly
kind of giving you a message if you know
what I mean everyone complained when
something is political but everything's
political like I said before it only
bothers you when you don't agree with it
but at the same time you also get with
something to be heavy-handed right
whether you agree with something or you
don't there's some movies where they
forget to be movies and they're just
like a dude with a bullhorn right like
they forget the artistic part of it but
the thing was sorry to bother you is
that this movie can be released 40 years
ago I think if it released two centuries
from now and it would still apply
because my man wasn't concerned and
chubby you know courage connections into
this thing
now this is based on marketers who are
known for the saying sorry to bother you
as they intrude in your daily lives and
I like this movie literally visually
shows you them appearing right before
you yeah cash is in this bill was a dude
just trying to make it by moving up the
ranks
it's beautiful in Detroit who creates
art and repels more than her character
did in the door
squeeze beautifully goes town to town
creating protests and starting up unions
and his friends oh my man was doing
interviews and a Mighty Morphin shirt
the movie is just as chill as that the
big thing about the business right yeah
it's still a marketing agency that's all
about sticking to the script which is
obviously a metaphor to how you know
everyone nowadays just sticks to a
certain norm right to court High School
Musical gets promoted and has to leave
everyone behind you think is very
interesting debate right because I'm
sure some of you have had that view you
know you get a little money and then
people think that all of a sudden you've
changed you guys that they're like oh
yeah I could finally afford an you sure
sort of debate yeah he did leave his
boys in the cops behind but at the same
time the boys and the cons were giving
him the money he needed to feed his
family and Uncle Terry needs those games
the tables were the way that he finds
success is that finding his white boys
which isn't just sounding like you need
Nasonex but that you sound worried free
that you speak with such ease and pride
that people listen
of course you gotta watch this movie
from an absurdist point of view right
it's not super real there's a bunch of
magical stuff that happens but I love
all the white voices are voiced by Rick
any manager of the Chipmunks who's
voicing cash damn ratatouille Oswald
who's voicing a Lawry's character but I
realize I thought we were all David
supposed to be the one who's rebelling
against all of this she has her a white
British voice but she's putting on a
performance because the metaphor of the
white boys which even applies to white
people is that it's all about us
pretending to be something that we're
not with that also comes out we're numb
to a bunch of things right like the
movie shows you a show that everyone
watches which is pretty much people
getting beat up which we kind of already
watch that stuff now there's a girl who
signs a six-figure deal just for going
viral at a protest because you created a
meme and that tends to happen now so
when they get into the word free part of
things right worry free being the
company that takes a page out of
downsizing and pitches people a place
where everything is provided for them
worry free hey just gotta work in these
factories and live in these strip down
ha styles that makes you start going I
feel like we're gonna see an ad for this
in five years but he's running worryfree
but the problem is that he's not only
playing as evil CEO explain this evil
CEO a little too well like he took both
twinkle ass twins and then just times
them by three so you have post-traumatic
stress disorder over here and the
opposite side of the pendulum swing is
to post-traumatic growth which which is
an actual condition where instead of
saying I was in a situation that
traumatized me and I'll never recover
you're in a traumatic situation and what
you do to compensate is say I will never
be in that situation that's called
getting out of a trap man what's easily
the craziest part of the movie is this
plan to turn the humans who are in his
worryfree facility into horses to create
these thugs that they can be a more
efficient species so they
handle labor better or 100 million
dollars in cash to cash so that he can
be their horse Moses this man wants to
fabricate an MLK before they even riot
so he has a spy on the end
that's why can you imagine a big
companies in our weird world where
actually responsible for the riots that
are held against them right they're the
ones inciting the the incidents because
they know insurance will cover it
whether it will benefit them that would
be crazy - crazy but let me explain
where works right I personally believe
the farther you get from reality the
better it is to view reality like
obviously it's a metaphor right of
turning people into work forces the idea
of some minorities with the phrase hung
like a horse ironically I would even
compare it to Bojack horseman you know
not just because I'm a cartoon and I
love a show but because that's an
absurdist cartoon where it handles
depression better than a lot of drama
series this one does - when this thing
gets so crazy that you can't help but
laugh you kind of see things more
objectively on top of that it's a
character art Cash's the entire movie is
sticking to the script he never stands
up for what he believes in until he
himself literally becomes a horse you
know the metaphor of literally becoming
a new person that he finally has a new
outlook on life and he finally starts
fighting for the cost I also love that
this movie's a bunch of Easter eggs
which makes you want to rewatch it like
Forest Whitaker produces the movie but
he also voices the first horse you see
Michelle country's offense has really
made these stuff it's kind of like he's
in a little Easter egg during the
stop-motion video which I thought was
cool knowing that Cassius eventually
will become a horse explains that scene
where he trips after he chases that car
that splashes him because baby horses
have weak
with the coolest one if you're able to
blow my mind down to love as long as you
don't tape it in your weight I may have
an easy video that gets even deeper than
what I did in this one better
here's definitely let me know down below
in the comment section whether work for
you whether it did it I know so we broke
up and I'm going now don't forget to
comment like and subscribe down below
and I'll send you some jack-in-the-box
alright cuz it's record a video very
well constructive video this guy put
together man right yeah I mean this
movie is a very very strange movie and
he definitely did open my eyes a lot
more as to what was really going on in
that film I was so taken aback by when
the horses appeared yeah that I wasn't
even registering with the metaphor was
yes so like what's going on right now
it's so lucky especially watching in a
theatre where you think you know where
this is going
yeah like oh he's about to meet top
corporate white guy play by Armie Hammer
he's gonna offer him some money this is
probably where he's gonna start
realizing what's going on in his life
and it it does but just not such a
different all the way you expected that
to happen and in such a disconcert like
whether it works or not it definitely
impacts you in that moment yeah for sure
I like what he points out here about
just the use of politics I guess because
one of the things I appreciated a lot
about this movie is the fact that it is
like very political if the main sub plot
is about a union half a day and you know
workers rights and you know some
reasonably socialist ideas and that
could have become something that was you
know it's like I share a certain amount
with this movie sure but you know
sitting there I was like this works even
if I didn't care about what was going on
like even if I didn't think this was
relevant at all or even if I was against
this kind of thing I'm still like it's
not getting in the way of the telling
the story so much is it's just a part of
the world of it I like that it seemed
like the part of a journey of a life you
know because you do have this political
situation but it's also very real in the
sense that when he gets promoted to
power color and stuff like that you're
like well what would I do because you
got to pay the bills that I know you're
gonna lose your place cuz your uncles on
the outs like yeah I feel like that was
one of my favorite things that he
touched on is yeah the way that
everything is political in its own way
and this movie sort of avoids feeling
like it's just trying to preach you by
being a full-on movie I think that's
where a lot of the fantastical elements
helped for me to cuz I was like oh like
you're really bothering to not just tell
me yeah what you believe about this
particular topic what did you think
about when he turns into a horse at the
end ah that's the one part I'm still
kind of wondering about because it's so
satisfying the way you think it ends up
and then when he starts to turn it's
almost like a horror movie at that point
it's like a gotcha well yeah because it
is like ode he did fulfill the role at
Armie Hammer set out to do but he didn't
pay him yeah it's like he didn't even
mean like it just happened anyway yeah
yeah there's a great quote that Steven
Yeun says at the end of the movie is
like if you show people a problem they
have no idea how to harness they'll just
get used to the problem the main plot
points I really liked and there were
even side story lines I liked my weird
problems coming with like nitpicks like
Steven Yeun sleeps with Tessa Thompson
or doesn't sleep but does stuff ideas
were they established right like they
don't yeah everything but yeah from just
like a script standpoint I was like what
was the point of that everything so like
routed and messages and points and and
there was a one plot point I was like
were you looking for something for their
characters to do I really no one touches
on that because it's such a side thing
with the movie but it does become a
focal point for Tessa Thompson's
character and Steven Yeun like they're
flirting throughout and then they
eventually do stuff together yeah I kind
of took that as sort of a sense of cold
just given the situation like a little
life moment cuz part of what I really
liked about that moment is the
conclusion of that conversation where
he's like it's not gonna happen again
I don't want to know and he never
actually verifies it even though we know
and so I thought that was a nice
character choice and maybe the best I
can draw out of it is like oh maybe this
just says that her character is way more
attracted to somebody who's like
proactive and firm in their beliefs or
whatever because that becomes a lot of
conflict between her and cash is how
yeah - totally yeah and it's kind of
ineffectual until yeah I he touched on
that and that's the thing as I thought
the arc kind of wrapped for cash earlier
than that but him turning at the very
end is sort of the completion of that
where it's like oh [ __ ] I'm transformed
this is completely visceral I feel like
towards the end of the movie in the
third act he learns the lesson yeah yeah
but turning brings it fully yeah yeah
and then the only thing I'm left
wondering is like was this a super time
release version of the horse powder must
have been why did it take so long if
he's talking about the foreshadowing of
what he trips and falls and stuff yeah
yeah yeah in that way then hinting at it
and doing a very convincing job of
making you think it's not gonna happen
and then it does I was like oh [ __ ] like
yeah there are a lot of uneasy things
about this movie and that's kind of what
I appreciate the more I think about them
cuz I'm like yeah I could totally see
why you wouldn't like this choice it is
jarring weird choice yeah but at the
same time it kind of fits with the
overall shape of this movie to me one of
the most brilliant scenes in here and I
can't quote it but one of the most
brilliant scenes in here was one of the
most uncomfortable okay and one of the
funniest okay and one of the scenes you
shouldn't be laughing at simultaneously
is when he's an army hammers party
everyone's like rap oh god yeah but he
can't freestyle because he's black they
expect him to a lot of the movie it's
not only about him you know like how
white people view black people that's a
big part of it yeah how society tends to
view black people but in that specific
moment and he started to saying the
n-word repeatedly and the crowd starts
going nuts yeah
bunch of white people or dancing it back
yeah I know you can bust a rap right no
actually I can't rap rap rap rap rap a
lot of moments really stand out to me
but that specific moment did speak to me
in a lot of ways you know it's like a
weird very telling moment that doesn't
need to be a confrontation to get a
point across to you I don't know the
exact meaning of that scene but as a
person who's not black yeah it makes me
flash to moments where I'm like if I'm
listening to rap music and they're
saying the n-word yeah I'm like can I
speak along with this I'm like if
there's a black person around I'm
definitely not going to I'm doing a
karaoke song I'm definitely not going to
and yet we love that kind of music but
in order for that kind of music to be
produced a lot of times you need a life
of struggle you know so like I feel like
there's a lot of ways to interpret that
but and I found that very fascinating in
terms of like the musical point of a
boots really having a musical background
yeah you know oh we love this black
music yeah take everyone make it or I
want you to kind of have a struggling
tough life in order for that kind of
music to be produced we can have fun
with our big-ass fancy parties yeah and
ignore the context that brought a lot of
it yeah exactly yeah yeah hey we just
had this situation pop up in culture not
long ago cuz Kendrick Lamar pulled
somebody up on stage to rap along with
one of his songs
there was an N word in that verse and
she said it and it became in a debate
anyway it became like a Internet
controversy at the very least yeah
it is like a fascinating debate and the
other thing that he touches on in this
video about race in general that I
really appreciated about the movie
overall is the way that the white voice
conversation is more broad like the
trailer you're like oh if T fun and
absurd yeah white people but then when
he expands on it means is like white
people don't even all have the white
voice because it's not about just
sounding nasal sound the own nasal it's
like something like you don't have a
care got your bills paid you have a
punch if you chew you but really the
show in your Ferrari out there after you
get off this car like I love that they
got to that point where it's like it's
about sounding carefree worried for you
yeah yeah and that is fascinating
because it almost defies races even
though on the surface level it feels
very locked into races it's a very more
broad class or yeah thing and I don't
feel like there's a lot in this movie
you can chew on
it's a rewatchable movie like this is a
rewatchable phone yeah oh yeah all right
Jay well thanks for requesting this and
hey major things to let me explain for
putting this awesome video together Jay
glad you got your letter
your shirt's on its way buddy and we
love you man hope you're having a good
December and you have a Merry Christmas
my friend you guys can subscribe to the
let me explain YouTube channel we're
hitting that subscribe button right now
and you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
check us on patreon got a bunch of
goodies over there